[Música]
l
ah
[Música]
hola buenos días a todos bueno vengo
contarles un poco mi historia yo soy
profesora en educación especial soy
graduada de la universidad nacional de
río cuarto
la mayoría de los días de mi semana
trabajo en esta actividad realizo
procesos de inclusión educativa de
personas en situación de discapacidad en
diferentes instituciones de la ciudad de
río cuarto también cuento con una beca
de investigación donde cotidianamente
trabajo
estoy terminando mis estudios como
licenciada en educación especial
realizó varias tareas durante la semana
luego contarles un poco esto
la verdad es que lo que a mí me gusta
mucho es trabajar con niños y es una
tarea que me apasiona
con ellos trabajo muchas veces ato
cordones cerco lágrimas abrazo a los
niños cuando están angustiados los
invito a jugar el piedra papel o tijera
muchas veces tengo que recordar que la
diversión es lo que importa
si algunas veces puede ser un poco más
autoritaria y otras veces aplicar un
poco más la docencia otra de las
actividades que realizó generalmente la
gente me pregunta si hago actividad
física yo digo que sí porque considero
que mi trabajo es un deporte si en
cierta forma es un deporte tomo
decisiones con la mayor imparcialidad
posible y en estas a veces solo
equivocarme si suelen juzgarme por
equivocarme los invito a que me levante
la mano quien de ustedes alguna vez en
su vida toma una decisión y se equivocó
o las dos manos me levanté en algo no es
que lindo bueno es muy bueno eso les
cuento algo más soy árbitro de fútbol sí
y la verdad que en la tarea más difícil
es tener que tomar decisiones en
fracción de segundos y que sea la
correcta
si eso es algunos entienden algunos
jugadores técnicos entrenadores
entienden que el error es parte de
nuestro trabajo nos reconocen como tal y
hay otros que les cuesta un poco más
como árbitro nosotros reconocemos
nuestros errores en muchas ocasiones en
otras nos cuesta un poco más obviamente
pero la culpa siempre tiene el árbitro
si un momento pero una mitad de cancha
cuando cruzamos la mitad de la cancha
para el otro lado hasta cuando cobras
algo bien está aquel quien no fue el
cancha él no escuchó por fin cobras de
una y te aplauden pero nada con
sinceridad lo hacen como un acto irónico
no
bueno les quiero contar que la presión
que genera el público sobre los
jugadores es increíble pero más aún
sobre la terna arbitral si el tener que
tomar las decisiones en fracción de
segundo y que sea la correcta es muy
difícil en esto y en esto donde yo por
ahí encuentro esto de poder conjugar la
docencia con el arbitraje sí porque como
árbitro de han sido quien se queda
decidió quién se va tomó muchas
decisiones pero no como una forma de
autoritaria
el árbitro muchas veces tiene que tomar
decisiones y no sólo dentro del terreno
juego sino detrás del alambrado si
muchas veces tenemos que recordarle a la
gente esto que le diversa en lo que
importa más que nada y generalmente
puedo aplicar la docencia en categorías
de inferiores cuando tenemos que
recordarle a un técnico quisiera estar
gritando es el ejemplo que le está dando
en línea
otras veces tenemos que recordarle a los
papás que si van a gritar que sea para
alentar su hijo porque realmente el
error del árbitro no lo van a remediar
indicación que el técnico no va a salir
detrás del alambrado a los nenes muchas
veces les podemos enseñar que golpearse
y si se golpean es un momento para pedir
disculpas si para darse las manos y
volver en pensar para divertirse porque
para eso es el fútbol
la realidad es que el trato que recibo
de los jugadores es enorme de jugadores
tenemos hoy en día en nuestra liga el
fútbol femenino ahí estamos bastante de
igual a igual en el trato pero cuando
tenemos el trato
de primera división es muy diferente al
del resto si tenemos a aquel que
simplemente te juzga por ser mujer y
hasta antes de ingresar al terreno de
juego si es mujer se le vaya el partido
hermano olvidado y así tenemos aquí el
otro que reconoce que hay mucho trabajo
detrás de esto hay mucho trabajo porque
uno puede dirigir en primera división y
en eso reconocen el temperamento que
conocen de cada uno de nosotros
la verdad es que es enorme el trato que
recibimos algunas veces es malo y otras
veces muy bueno y gratificante si el
control emocional que tiene que tener el
árbitro dentro del terreno de juego es
muy difícil de lograr siendo que el
trato que recibimos es totalmente
diferente el árbitro tiene que tener un
control emocional siempre tiene que
tratar de responder bien al otro
en esto he aprendido a lo largo de los
años
que
la tarea arbitral y el error es
inherente a la tarea del árbitro es así
no hay otra la verdad es que me pasa que
antes de pitar cada jugada
uno tiene que sacarle una foto la jugada
y tiene que tomar en milésimas de
segundos la decisión correcta saber cómo
va a renovar el juego y luego qué
sanción va a aplicar es en eso que les
cuento algo uno pinta la jugada si tenés
de todo este lado la gente que te está
gritando y que está insultando
pero por otro lado tenemos el jugador en
el piso que se agarra el tobillo se da
vuelta de un lado para el otro que se
está muriendo del dolor el jugador
infractor pero no dice nada
y ya tenemos el técnico
el técnico del que se golpeó y que te
dice lo tenés que echar e no me caben
dudas
el técnico del otro lado que te dice que
cobre antes y no hizo nada bueno es en
todo eso que uno tiene que tomar la
decisión correcta claro siempre me sale
bien si en eso está el crecimiento o no
de uno como árbitro me pasó que empecé
el arbitraje desde muy chica y debuta en
primera división desde muy chica también
con tan sólo 19 años sí en eso
tuve la suerte de tener gente donde me
formé en la asociación riocuartense de
árbitro de fútbol tuve un instructor
jorge luis carballo introductor nacional
donde él como así también cada uno de
mis compañeros del arbitraje fueron
marcando me cada error que iba teniendo
y no como una forma de criticarme o de
tirarme para abajo realmente esos que te
critican en esta tarea son ellos que te
quieren ver crecer y fue lo que fui poco
a poco logrando sí y aprendiendo esto de
que el error es inherente la tarea del
árbitro
en los medios de comunicación y
tecnológicos generalmente la gente
cotidianamente me pregunta qué opina
sobre la tecnología y los medios de
comunicación
a ver consideró que los avances que dio
la tecnología son enormes igual que la
comunicación sí pero también siempre
pienso y los invito a que se pongan un
minuto en esas patillas del árbitro
piensen con tantas presiones y con todo
lo que tienen que resolver en 90 minutos
tomar siempre la decisión correcta
mientras otras tienen la suerte de sacar
conclusiones detrás de una cámara donde
pueden realizar la cámara lenta hacerlo
es una jugada míralo 23 veces sentados
tranquilos
es difícil lo sé y ahí recién saca una
conclusión bueno el árbitro tiene
milésimas de segundos si solo milésimas
de segundo para sacar la conclusión de
esa jugada
del fútbol tenemos gran cantidad de
personas que participan tenemos a
aquellos que solo son simpatizantes
tenemos a los que son jugadores y a los
que como nosotros llamamos están en el
cuerpo técnico son entrenador técnico
propiamente dicho y demás en ellos
realmente veo la diferencia que existe
entre aquellos que juegan y aquellos que
trabajan del fútbol si lo veo cuando por
ejemplo en las categorías de primera
división los intereses que se mueven son
muy diferentes tanto económicos como de
ascenso de categoría porque un jugador
cuando realizó un gol o cuando tiene una
victoria un ascenso tienen realmente una
corporalidad muy diferente a cuando lo
vean los pequeñitos esos les gusta
realmente gana si a esos cuando pierden
uno ve el mar de lágrimas que dejan en
la cancha así es y cuando ganan se van
con esa sonrisa enorme se sacan la
camisa de tita y le revolvían para todos
lados y se van a abrazar el familiar que
tienen afuera si ahí hay una cuestión
que esto mismo que siempre me pregunto y
es en qué momento uno deja de jugar para
empezar a trabajar en el fútbol
y en este mismo momento es donde yo veo
y siempre hay una cuestión que me hace
mucho ruido y es pensar en qué momento
se va la honestidad de uno cuando es
pequeño
si a mí me pasa generalmente en las
categorías de inferiores donde veo
muchísimas situaciones un día como
cualquier otro donde un arquerito
chiquitito 67 años
estábamos en pleno partido un jugador
remata hacia el arco
remate hacia el arco el balón sales
afuera yo la verdad que venía un poquito
lejos de la jugada y fue una jugada
bastante rápida me encuentro a cerca del
arquerito y la agache la cabeza con un
miedo terrible y me dice me tocó el
balón en las manos
claro imagínense que de este lado como
siempre los papas gritando arco desde el
otro lado gritando se quede aquí en esa
esquina bien en ese momento y si acaso
ese arquero porque él me estaba diciendo
la verdad le había tocado la mano sobre
el saque de esquina reanudó el juego
cabezazo
pregúnteme como también la jugada en gol
que tiene la culpa de la resta siempre
siempre siempre siempre en esto veo una
gran diferencia cuando dirigimos por dos
de primera cuando dirigimos los
pequeñitos los pequeñitos te invitan a
jugar te invitan a ser parte de ese
juego de ese error honesto siempre se
equivocan de forma honesta
en cambio el fútbol de primera nos pasa
muchas veces que tenemos que
enfrentarnos a un tiene un trabajo donde
el margen de error prácticamente no
puede existir prácticamente no puede
existir y el disfrute no siempre tiene
el lugar primordial creo que estamos en
un momento de cambio en un momento donde
hay un montón de cuestiones que nos
tenemos que empezar a replantear porque
el fútbol es el deporte más convocante
del mundo si en esto siempre pienso y
sierra dedicamos que el árbitro hay que
insultarlo
y si desnaturalizamos esto de tener que
todo el tiempo estar echándole la culpa
al otro exteriorizar el error en el otro
y pienso en esto el fútbol es el deporte
más convocantes del mundo donde hay
cantidad de personas que lo integran
pero no así mi tarea como árbitro es por
eso que tengo un gran orgullo de
defender la camiseta negra de defender
el juego limpio y el disfrute de todos
creo que en esto en este cambio están
implicado cada uno de todos ustedes en
esto de poder seguir errando realmente
los invito a errar a errar
honestamente porque esa es la verdadera
esencia de lo humano muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a